Nothing is more glamorous
than walking the red carpet.
Unless you're me!
Bing!
My name is Jason Bolden,
Creative Director for JSN Studio,
where we do interior design
and celebrity styling.
I'm Adair Curtis, Jason's better half.
I oversee the interior design,
and while Jason is running his mouth,
I'm running our business.
Where do you come up with this stuff?
Our clients are real life superstars.
Why am I getting actual chills though?
This is your kitchen.
-Wow!
-This is crazy, man.
Oh, my God!
Amazing!
Women that we work with
are the epitome of black girl magic.
But it's definitely not easy.
It's the day before the Emmys.
It's a hole in the dress.
You are no longer part of JSN Studio.
We are done.
We've never really heard about
black interior decorators
and celebrity stylists.
The demand is really high for us.
You married a superstar.
I did.
You're my Ivanka.
Well, we getting a divorce.